if we look at George W bush and maybe
you can give me insights this is what's
fascinating to me when you have
extremely competent
uh smart hard-working
well-intentioned people how do we as a
system uh make mistakes in foreign
policy so the big mistake uh you can
characterize in different ways but in
George W bush is invading Iraq yeah or
maybe how it was invaded or maybe how
the decision process was made to invade
it uh again Afghanistan but
but maybe not the invasion but details
around like having a plan about you know
how to withdraw all that kind of stuff
then Barack Obama
to me similarly is is the man who came
to fame early on for being somebody who
was against a rare voice against the
invasion of Iraq which was actually a a
brave thing to do at that time
and nevertheless he and I mean I don't
know the numbers but I think he was the
president for eight years over increased
drone attacks increa like ever
everything from a foreign policy
perspective uh the the
military-industrial complex that machine
grew in power under him not shrunk and
did not withdraw
from Afghanistan and then
um with Donald Trump the criticisms that
you're presenting sort of uh the the
personal attacks the chaos the
partisanship of people that are supposed
to be nonpartisan so that you know if
you do sort of the Steel Man the chaos
to to make the case for chaos maybe we
need to shake up the machine
throw a wrench into the engine into the
gears and then every individual gear is
going to be very upset with that because
it's the wrench it's not it's not it's
an inefficient process but maybe it
leads uh for government it forces the
the system as a whole not the
individuals but the system to reconsider
how things are done so obviously all of
those things
uh the actual results are not that
impressive
Quest questioning and trying to shake
things up as well and do things
different
but you know the question is if you
bring the whole system down with nothing
ideas of putting it to play it's like I
mean I'm like many people I've studied
the Bolshevik Revolution and you know
many others as well and you know kind of
what's what you know what's the pattern
here or you know that actually fits into
what you're talking about here is the
kind of rigidity of thought on the part
of revolutionaries in many cases as well
and also narcissism
in fact I think it takes a pretty you
know strong sense of yourself you know
kind of an owning yourself to want to be
present in the United States for example
we see that in you know many of our
presidents have been narcissists to
different you know kind of degrees you
think about Lenin you know for example
and people can go back and read about
Lenin he formed his views when he was
about 18 and he never shook them off he
never evolved he he didn't have any kind
of diversity of thought
and on when systems go awry it's when
they don't bring in different
perspectives
and so you know Trump have you brought
in different perspectives and actually
listen to them and not just you know
believe that he himself knew better than
anyone else and then tried to divide
everybody against each other would have
been a different matter it's a tragedy
of a completely and utterly lost set of
opportunities because of the flaws in
his own nature
because I mean again there was all kinds
of things that he could have done to
shake things up and so many people
around him remained completely
disappointed and of course he divided
and pitted people against each other you
know creating so much factionalism in
American politics that you know people
have forgotten they're Americans they
think that they're red or blue you know
parts of teams and you know if you go
back over history that's kind of a
recipe for for war and you know internal
conflict you go back to you know the
Byzantine empire for example there's a
famous episode of the Nikki riots uh in
uh Constantinople where the whole city
gets trashed because the greens the Reds
the blues and these various sporting
teams in the Hippodrome get whipped up
by political forces and the you know
they pull the place apart and that's you
know kind of where we've been heading on
some of these trajectories but the other
point is when you look back you know at
Bush and a bummer as well there's a very
narrow circle of decision making you
know Bush period it's the focus on the
executive branch
um with uh Dick Cheney is the vice
president being very fixated on it and
Obama it's you know he and you know kind
of the Bright Young things around him
you know from himself as you know kind
of intellectually
um you know one might uh say arrogant in
many respects you know he was very smart
guy and you know he's convinced that he
has any he ruminates over all things but
he's the person who makes you know a lot
of decisions
and
um basically George W bush used to call
himself the decider as well right I mean
they're all the people who make the
decisions it's not always as
consultative as you might think it is
and for Trump it's like I'm not
listening to anybody at all you know
it's just me and whatever it is that I'm
walking up today and I've decided to do
so I think you know the problem with all
of our systems why we don't get results
is because we don't draw upon you know
the diversity of opinion and all the
ideas of you know people out there like
you do that in science I mean one I mean
all my friends and relatives are in
science they've got this incredible
collaborations with people you know
across the world I mean how did we get
to these vaccines for the curve advice
because of this incredible years of
collaboration and of you know sharing
results and sharing on ideas and our
whole system has become ossified you
know we think about the Congressional
system for example as well and there's
you know this kind of Rapid you know
turnover that you're having uh Congress
every two years you know there's no
incentive for people you know basically
to work with others they're constantly
campaigning they're constantly trying to
appeal to whatever their base is and
they don't really care about you know
some do you know of their constituents
but a lot of people don't and the Senate
it's all kind of focused on the game of
uh of legislation uh for for so many
people as well not focusing again on
that kind of sense about what are we
doing like scientists to kind of work
together you know for the good of the
country to push things along and also
our government also is siled there's not
a lot of mechanisms for bringing people
together they ought to be in things like
the National Security Council the
National Intelligence Council actually
did that quite successfully at times for
analysis that I saw but we don't have
you know we have it within the National
Institutes of Health but we saw the CDC
breakdown on this you know kind of front
we we don't have sufficient of those
institutions that bring people together
from all kinds of different backgrounds
you know one of the other problems that
we've have with government with the
federal government over you know state
and local government is actually quite
small people think that the federal
government's huge because we're a postal
service in the military that are part of
it but your actual federal government
employees is a very small number
and you know the senior executive
service part of that is the older white
guys you know kind of come up all the
way over the last you know several
decades we have a really hard time
bringing in younger people into that
kind of government service and that's
their political hacks you know and I
want to you know kind of or they're kind
of looking for power and you know sort
of influence
we have a hard time getting people like
yourself another you know younger people
kind of coming in
to make a career out of uh public
service and also retaining them because
you know people with Incredible skills
often get poached away into the private
sector and you know a lot of the people
that I work with in the National
Security side are now what all kinds of
you know high-end political
consultancies or they've gone to Silicon
Valley and they've they've gone to this
place in that place because after a time
as a younger person they're not you know
rising up particularly quickly because
there's a pretty rigid way of looking at
the the hierarchies and the promotion
schemes and they're also getting
lambasted by everybody people like ah
you know public servants they're not
really public servants there's this
whole lack and loss
um of a kind of a faith in public
service
and you know the last few years I've
really done a lot of damage we need to
revitalize
uh our government system to get better
results we need to bring more people in
even if it's you know for a period of
time not just through expensive
contracts for you know the the big
Consulting companies and you know other
entities that do government work out
there but getting into people in for a
period of time expending expanding some
of these management fellowships and the
White House fellows and you know
bringing in you know scientists uh you
know from the outside giving you know
that that kind of opportunity for
collaboration that we see in other
spheres I think that's actually one of
the biggest roles
for a president that
for some reason during the election
that's never talked about is how good
are you at hiring yeah and and creating
a culture of like attracting the right I
mean basically Chief hire when you think
of a CEO
like the great CEOs are
I mean maybe people don't talk about it
that often but they do more often for
CEOs than they do for presidents it's
like how good are you building a team
well we make it really difficult because
the political process I mean and also
because we have so many political
appointments we don't have less to be
honest I mean we look at other
governments around the world you know
that are smaller it's much easier for
them to hire people in yeah you know
some of the most successful governments
are much smaller and it's not that I say
that you know the government is
necessarily too big but it's just
thinking about each unit in a different
way we shouldn't be having so many
political appointments we should kind of
find more professional appointments more
non-parties on appointments because you
know with every single Administration
that we've had over the last of the span
of presidency they have jobs that are
unfulfilled because they can't get their
candidates through Congress and the
Senate because of all the political
games that are being played I know loads
of people have just been held up because
it's just on the whim of you know some
member of Congress even though that the
actual position that they want is really
Technical and doesn't really care about
what you know what political you know
Preference they particularly have so I
think we have to try to look at the
whole system of governments in the way
that we would over you know other
professional
sectors and to try to think about this
as just as you said there that this is a
government that's actually running our
country this is an operating system and
you wouldn't operate it like that if you
were you know looking at in any kind of
rational way it shouldn't be so
ideologically or parties untainted so
years every level anyway so I would
actually just make a bid for a more
non-partisan approach to a lot of the
parts of government you can still kind
of bring in you know the political and
premature but also you have to explain
to people writ large in America as well
that this is your government yeah and
that actually you could also be part of
this yeah things like the small business
administration yes Department of
Agriculture you know all these kind of
things that actually people interact
with but they don't even know it the
Postal Service you know all of these
things I mean people actually when you
ask them about uh different functions of
government they have a lot of support
for the National Park Service you know
for example it's just when you talk
about government in an abstract where
like oh yeah no too much bloated you
know not efficient and effective but if
you kind of bring it down more to the
kind of local and federal levels that's
kind of you know when people really see
it and if people could see kind of
themselves reflected and many other
people have gone into public service I
think that they would yeah they have a
lot more support for it more like
Superstars like uh
individuals that are like big on social
media big in the public eye and having
fun with it and showing cool stuff that
it's not there's right now a lot of
people see government as basically
partisan Warfare and then
it just it makes it unpleasant to do the
job it makes it uninspiring for people
looking in from outside about what's
going on inside government all of it the
whole thing but you you are you know
just
with all due respect you're pretty rare
individual in terms of non-partisanship
like it just actually your whole life
story The The Humbling aspect of of your
upbringing and everything like that uh
do you think it's possible to have a lot
of non-partisan
experts in government like can you be a
top presidential advisor on Russia
for 10 years for 15 years and remain
nonpartisan I think you can I don't
think that's advisable though by the way
because I mean I don't think anybody
should be there you know so your first
advice is to fire yourself afterwards
you should you should definitely
have to think right I mean it's just
like tenure in universities
yeah you kind of you know we do we have
natural term limits but you know you're
kind of um you know basically bottling
it up for other people I mean you know
what I'm trying to do now I'm like I'm
57 now
um and I always try to work with you
know people from different generations
for me just like
you know I've really benefited from
these you know kind of mentorships of
people are older you can you know Mentor
up and well and Mentor down I mean I
would you know try to get you know
people from different backgrounds and
different generations to work together
in teams obviously I'd like to more team
networked uh kind of approach to things
not the kind of things that you get
again in science right I mean all these
ideas are going to come from all kinds
of different perspectives age and
experience does count for something but
you know fresh ideas and coming in and
looking at a problem from a different
perspective and seeing something that
somebody else hasn't seen before I mean
I just you know kind of love working in
a an environment with all kinds of
different people and people who don't
agree with you you need people to take
you on and say absolute that's crap you
know kind of where did you come up with
that from and go hang on well well
explain to me why you think so and then
you know you have this kind of iterative
process back and forth I mean I would
always encourage my colleagues to tell
me when they thought it was wrong I mean
sometimes I didn't agree because I
didn't see the the
um you know the reasoning but other
times I'm like they're right I you know
but that was a complete mistake I I need
to admit that and you know kind of we
need to figure out a different way of
doing things but at one point I do want
to get across is there were a lot of
people who were non-partisan that I
worked with I mean honestly in most of
the jobs that I had up until more
recently I had no idea about people's
political affiliation it's just when you
get into this kind of Highly charged
partisan environment they kind of force
people you know to make decisions and
when you have you know one political
party or political fashion that's trying
to use serp power it does make it quite
difficult I mean that's the situation
that we're in right now and you know
we're seeing some of the things
happening since I've seen and studied in
other settings or seen for myself
happening you know when you have
um a president who wants to cling on to
power you know you've got you've got to
call that out you know is that a
partisan act or is that a kind of you
know defense of that larger uh political
system that that you're part of you know
so I think we've got to recognize that
even if you're not partisan you can be
politically engaged and you know
sometimes you just have to stand up
there and speak out which is you know
what I did what others did as well none
of those people who spoke out you know
can initially saw that as a partisan act
even if some of them since then have
decided to make political choices they
hadn't made before because in the
situation actually forced people into
you know taking sites very hard to still
stay above The Fray when you've got you
know someone who's trying to perpetrate
a coup yeah just to linger on that I
think it's hard and it's the courageous
thing to do to criticize a president and
not fall into partisanship after because
the whole world will assume if you
criticize Donald Trump that you're
clearly
uh a Democrat and so they will just
everybody will criticize you for being a
Democrat and then so you're now stuck in
that so you're going to just Embrace
that role but to still walk the
nonpartisan route after the criticism
that's the hard Road uh so not let the
criticisms break you into uh
you know and into a certain kind of
ideological set of positions I mean our
political system didn't it's
revitalization we need to be taking a
long hard look at ourselves here and I
think what people are calling out for
look there's a vast with a population of
like me who were unaffiliated you know
maybe some lean in One Direction Over
another and unaffiliated doesn't mean
you don't have views about things and
political opinions and you know you may
sound quite extreme on you know some of
those you know by the from a left or
right right perspective what people are
looking for is kind of an articulation
you know things in a kind of a clear way
that they can get a handle on and
they're also looking for a
representation somebody's going to be
there on you know for you you know not
part of a kind of a rigid team that
you're excluded from you're the ins and
the outs but what people are looking at
now they're looking at that in the
workplace because they're not finding
that
in politics you're actually getting
workers you know pushing the people talk
about the rise of the workers people
just saying hang on a sec you know the
most important space that I'm in right
now
is my workplace because that's where my
benefits are from they're not coming
from the state I mean that's the
peculiarity of the United States system
you know the Britain you've got the
National Health Service and you've got
all the kind of national wide benefits
you know you're not Tethered to your
employer like you are in the United
States but here now we're asking people
you know people are pushing
uh for more representation they're
asking to be represented within their
workplace be it Starbucks where Boris
deserve you know another Starbucks
employees are trying to unionize we have
unions among our research assistants the
bookings institution where I am you know
kind of teaching assistants in big
universities doing the same kind of
thing as well because they won't have
their boys heard they want to kind of
play a larger role they want to have
change and they're often pushing their
companies or the institutions they work
for to make that change because they
don't see it happening
um uh in the political sphere so it's
not just enough to go out there and
protest in the street but if you want
something to happen that's why you're
seeing big corporations playing a bigger
role as well
yeah and of course there's you know this
is the longest discussion there's also
criticisms of that mechanisms of unions
that to achieve the giving of a voice to
a people this goes back to my own
experience growing up in northern
England
the Durham miners
that I was part of for Generations you
know first person in my family not in
the mines on my dad's side
um they created their own Association it
wasn't a union person at the very
beginning the later that became part of
the national miners Union they lost
their autonomy and Independence as a
result of that but what they did was
they pulled their resources they set up
their own Parliament so they could all
get together literally they built a
parliament and it you know opened in
like the same time as World War one and
where they all got together because they
didn't have the vote they didn't have
suffrage at the time because they didn't
have any money you know so they didn't
compare the tax and they you know they
couldn't run for Parliament and this is
you know the kind of the origins of the
organized labor parties later but they
create this Association so they could
talk about how they could deal with
things of their own communities and have
a voice in the things that mattered you
know education you know improving their
work conditions it wasn't like what you
think about some kind of like big
political Trade union with you know
left-wing you know kind of ideas and in
fact they actually tried to root out
later after the Bolshevik Revolution in
the Soviet Union even when they were
still having ties with players like the
minds of Don bass in the 1920s
trotskyites and you know kind of
londonists and you know Communists they
were more focused on how to improve
their own well-being you know what they
call the welfare they had some welfare
societies where they were kind of trying
to think and that's kind of what
Baristas in Starbucks want or workers in
Amazon they're talking about their own
well-being it's not just about pay and
work conditions it's about what it means
to be part of this large entity because
you're not feeling that same kind of
connection
to politics you know at the moment
because you know you're being told by a
representative sorry I don't represent
you because you didn't vote for me you
know if you're not a Democrat you're not
a republican you're not red you know
you're not blue you're not mine and so
people are saying well I'm in this
workplace this is kind of my Collective
you know this is this is you know their
fault this is what I'm gonna have to try
to push to make change so I mean this is
kind of happening here and we have to
you know realize that you know we've
kind of gone and we're full circle back
to that you know kind of period of the
early emergence of sort of mass labor
and you know the way that that's where
the political parties that we know today
and you know the kind of early unions
came out of as well this sort of feeling
of a mass Society but where people
weren't really able to
get together and Implement uh or push
for change you know with unions at a
small scale and a local scale it's like
every good idea
on a small scale can become a bad idea
in a large on a large scale so like uh
marriage is a beautiful thing but at a
large scale it becomes the marriage
industrial complex that tries to make
money off of it combined with the
lawyers that try to make money off the
divorce uh it just becomes there you go
caricature of a thing or like uh
Christmas in the holidays it's like it's
just I I don't disagree but what I'm
saying is there's K-pop people are
basically looking for something here and
you know kind of this is why I mean I
myself them start to think about much
more local you know kind of solutions to
a lot of these you know kind of problems
is again the teamed networked approach